decades after we first met the Taylor
family it's impossible to picture Tim
Allen's over-ambitious handyman / TV
host Tim the Toolman Taylor married to
anyone but his smart cool vest wearing
wife Jill played by patricia richardson
years after the show's end in May 1999
Richardson recalled that the pair's
chemistry on the show was instantly
clear telling HuffPost live Tim was so
hilarious and we just clicked right away
it was a really fast five or six days
when we did the pilot even after the
home-improvement series finale the
actress found it weird watching her
co-star with his other on-screen wives
Richardson once joked whenever I see him
with other people I think while he was
mine first bolstered by an actress with
whom he had a natural rapport Alan
captivated audiences on home improvement
which served as a big Hollywood break
propelling him from stand-up comedian to
the lead in the Christmas classic the
Santa Claus in 1994 he went on to voice
Buzz Lightyear in Toy Story a year after
that all while continuing to film the
sitcom Richardson became beloved amongst
viewers at the time and maintains a
steady career to this day all this
considered one might assume that Alan
and Richardson were the obvious perfect
TV couple match from the get-go but the
truth is that Richardson wasn't Tim
Taylor's first on-screen wife before ABC
executives begged her to play Jill they
actually cast someone else in the role
on paper ABC's first pick for Jill
seemed sound the first version of the
home improvement pilot starred dramatic
actress Frances Fisher as the Taylor
family matriarch at the time Fisher's
most famous on-screen role was her
five-year stint as Detective Debra Saxon
in ABC's long-running crime drama soap
opera at the edge of night off screen
for a time she was best known in the
headlines as Clint Eastwood's girlfriend
Fisher dated the actor turned director
for almost six years after meeting him
on the set of the film in Cadillac in
1989 in which she had a small part
despite Fisher's stellar dramatic record
her talents didn't quite translate to
the boisterous jokes of home improvement
Richard Karn who plays Tim's
long-suffering tool time co-presenter al
Borland said the home improvement
writers changed their minds about Fisher
just three days into rehearsals after
the pilot didn't fly with audiences the
creative team scrambled to replace
Fisher with a dip
star car recalled Francis is a great
actress but in this role with Tim she
came off more as a victim to him than
he's equal I feel like I've gone through
so many things I never had to explain
and former Walt Disney television
president Dean Valentine told the
archive of American television that
Fisher's comedic skills simply weren't
up to the task of competing with Allen
she's really she's a wonderful actress
but she's not really as funny as he is
Fischer probably isn't dwelling too much
on losing the part she's had a brilliant
career on the small screen since
appearing on episodes of top-rated TV
shows like the x-files ER Grey's Anatomy
and Fargo perhaps most famously she
played roses icy mother Ruth in the 1997
blockbuster Titanic after changing their
minds about Fisher ABC executives almost
failed to convince patricia richardson
to take over at the time she'd just
given birth to twins and already had a
six-year-old at home and she was
supposed to go back to work on a
different show for the network in nine
months time when Richardson got the call
to say she'd been cast on home
improvement instead she resisted she
later told HuffPost live I had never
heard of Tim and I didn't know anything
about it
Richardson told the network brass they
would have to wait for her to breastfeed
her twins during filming and they agreed
but what finally convinced her was that
the producers had worked on her favorite
show Roseanne meanwhile Richardson's
husband at the time actor Ray Baker
immediately saw the potential he
reportedly told her this is the show
you're going to do for seven years
actually it turned out to be eight
Richardson returned for the eighth and
final season of home improvement because
she'd promised the crew she would but
was determined to leave after that she's
very clear on why Home Improvement was
canceled after season 8 she and Allen
didn't want to stay on for another
season no matter how much money a VC was
willing to pay additionally some of the
show's key voices weren't returning for
a potential ninth season including some
longtime writers and Richardson felt the
show was going to suffer as a result
Plus as she said she was burned out from
working long days including in the
writers room
she told HuffPost live I really just
felt like I need to get out of this show
and have a life again and see my
children and maybe have a date because I
had gotten divorced halfway through
Richardson contributed so much to the
sitcom by
after a long and wildly successful run
it was time to move on and to make a few
home improvements of her own check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the belle so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]